gouvernement travaille fortement pour
s'approprier les territoires des peuples
indigènes
si amazon et disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
à la une plusieurs centaines de
manifestants anti masque à paris
aujourd'hui le port de protections
obligatoires au visage s'étend dans
plusieurs grandes villes du pays face au
regain à des contaminations plus de 7300
car en 24 heures les derniers chiffres
même colère d'ailleurs à berlin et à
londres où l'on s'est fortement
mobilisée pour dire non aux mesures de
restriction
dans ce journal on s'interrogera sur le
recyclage d'anciens ministres d'emmanuel
bacon françois bayrou va être nommé haut
commissaire au plan et apparemment ce
n'était pas le seul à se faire rocade et
il y en ad'autres nous verrons cela dans
cette émission
[Musique]
et puis au mali la junte confirme
considérer son leader comme chef de
l'état pour l'instant toujours pas de
transfert du pouvoir aux civils malgré
la pression des pays d'afrique de
l'ouest des militaires reporter une
réunion prévue aujourd'hui avec les
organisations politiques et civiles du
pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france 1 samedi marquée
par une vague de manifestations contre
le port du masque obligatoire dans
l'hexagone et ailleurs en europe à
berlin
regardez 18000 personnes ont grondé leur
colère est la police berlinoise a
interrompu leur rassemblement
et puis vous allez voir même chose à
londres où les autorités pourraient
introduire de nouvelles mesures de
restriction contre la pandémie de covile
19 voyons s'immobiliser là bas aussi
à paris ils étaient moins nombreux
plusieurs centaines avec cette même
colère et ce refus de voir leur liberté
restreinte classe de la nation les
forces de l'ordre ont procédé à leur
dispersion le point avec estelle farce
eh bien écoutez ici le rassemblement
anti masque est en train de toucher à sa
fin vous le voyez peut-être derrière moi
les forces de l'ordre qui sont en train
d'évacuer à les manifestants des
manifestants qui se sont rassemblés sur
les coups de 13 heures pour dénoncer ce
qu'ils appellent une dictature sanitaire
ce sont leurs mots je vous propose de
les écouter c'est pas ces paniers primés
en plus c'est que
contre cotto nature mois mince partie
fin je vois pas pourquoi je mettrais un
masque parce que j'ai confiance en mon
immunité à c'est un rassemblement pour
les libertés
parce que là ce qui est en jeu c'est la
liberté c'est nos libertés
c'est un sujet
c'est quand même un truc de dingue je
veux dire nous empêche de subvenir à un
besoin vital qui est la respiration
donc là c'est juste pas supportable onu
musée comme peine des animaux mais c'est
une forme de dressage pour nous faire
accepter des choses encore qui voit
beaucoup plus grave
donc moi je préviens la population de se
révolter votre système de dictature qui
a en train de nous sommes pressés mais
qui en pratique on vous pressent le
monde entier voilà pour les
revendications sachez que ce
rassemblement était une première en
france un rassemblement à qui intervient
alors que le port du masque est en train
de devenir obligatoire dans de
nombreuses communes de l'hexagone
alors qui sont ces opposants au port du
masque d'où vient leur défiance
vis-à-vis des restrictions à sanitaire
éléments de réponse avec les la femme
rousse ou berlin londres madrid ou
encore bruxelles depuis plusieurs
semaines les manifestations contre le
port du masque et les restrictions
imposées pour lutter contre l'épidémie à
se multiplient en france alors que 38%
de la population ne veut pas porter le
masque en entreprise
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux que les
contestataires semblent les plus actifs
près de vingt mille personnes réparties
dans plusieurs groupes sur facebook
le nombre d'adhérents à ces pages
communautaires ne cesse d'augmenter
alors qui sont ces anti masque on a vu
ces derniers temps des médias dressé un
portrait peu flatteur de ce mouvement
contestataire les antilles masque
seraient des complotistes des militants
d'extrême droite ou encore les gilet
jaune en quête de visibilité
une étude réalisée récemment par un
chercheur à sciences po qui a contacté
un millier de personnes dans ces groupes
facebook d'étain des antilles masque de
façon bien plus complexe l'étude
démontre une surreprésentation des
catégories sociales plutôt élevés dans
ces groupes 36 % de cadres alors que ces
mêmes cadres ne représentent que 18% de
la population française et parmi les
arguments qui reviennent
l' entrave aux libertés individuelles ou
encore la gêne respiratoire
mais ce qu'il ressent avant tout c'est
une réelle défiance vis-à-vis des
institutions politiques et médiatiques
non seulement il a été dit et martelé
pendant des mois que les masques ne
servait à rien mais il a même été
expliqué avec beaucoup de pédagogie que
les masques étaient dangereux nous
assistons à un gouvernement qui ne sait
pas quoi faire pour ouvrir dès parapluie
pour se protéger d'éventuels recours en
justice et qui impose des mesures de
précaution qui sont pour certaines
d'entre elles extrêmement discutable il
faut bien reconnaître qu'en entre mars
et août
la volte face de l'exécutif n'a fait
qu'ajouter à la confusion
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune indication
acheter des masques les matchs n'ont
aucun intérêt pour le grand public le
port du masque en population générale
dans la rue ça ne sert à rien je suis
surpris de voir par la fenêtre de mon
ministère le nombre de personnes qui
sont dans la rue avec des masques alors
que cela ne correspond pas à des
recommandations
vous savez quoi moi je sais pas utiliser
un masque je pourrais dire je suis mini
je me mets un masque mais en fait je
sais pas l'utiliser mais même parmi les
professionnels de santé
l'obligation du port du masque dit lise
d'un point de vue sanitaire
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de débat il
faut porter le masque et dire je ne
porte pas le masque parce que c'est ma
liberté parce que celle d'un confortable
peu parce que moi je n'aime pas porter
le masque
ce n'est pas recevable lorsque nous
parlons de un enjeu dans lequel il y a
des vies en danger
j'aurais préféré qu'on reste à un niveau
de recommandations plus que
d'obligations parce que j'ai peur que ça
devienne encore quelque chose de clivant
de conflictuelle l'actualité semble
malheureusement donné raison professeur
à eau
ces dernières semaines plusieurs
personnes ont été agressées pour avoir
tout simplement à demander le respect
des gestes barrières
attention tout de même à ne pas faire le
parallèle entre ces faits divers
tragiques et un mouvement de
contestation plus large qui porte un
vrai questionnement politique
on va écouter l'analyse de stéphane
caillet médecins infectiologues au crh
u12 strasbourg
je pense en effet que la décision qui
est prise de rendre le masque
obligatoire à l'extérieur c'est une
c'est une décision
qui correspond à une inquiétude parce
que les pouvoirs publics
voyant le nombre n'ont pas de cas mais
deux porteurs du virus augmenté du fait
de l'augmentation des prélèvements et
bien prennent peur et on se disent on va
fermer les vannes on va fermer les
robinets
on va réduire encore la circulation du
virus en obligeant le port du masque à
l'extérieur mais en effet c'est une
décision qui correspond à une stratégie
politique mais qui n'a pas vraiment de
justification sur le plan
épidémiologique et je pense qu'elle peut
être contre-productive parce que ça
contribue et on le voit à agacer les
gens parce que tout simplement beaucoup
d'avis d'épidémiologistes commencent à
se faire entendre et les le grand public
commence à savoir que cette mesure a
énormément de mal à être justifié les
gilet jaune de leur côté à ils font leur
rentrée manifestent contre les violences
policières en attendant le grand rendez
vous du 12 septembre
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines de
militants entre la porte de champerret à
paris est la place de la bastille on les
a aussi remarqué
du côté de vincennes où un banquet était
organisée contre la précarité écouter
certains militants au micro de cynthia
lauvergeon s'est mise en jambes
la voilà ces moyens du berry j'ai fait
300 km heure entre ah voilà et on est
déterminés pour le 12 sept ans pour
aller sur les champs elysées mais ces
macro il nous a dit il ya quelques
semaines une révolution ne s'invite pas
c'est le peuple qui la décide et le 10
septembre y donnent rendez vous nous
allons la prendre cette révolution
on sera déterminés on nous voulons plus
de justice sociale
- de culpabilisation des démunis tout
est à deux vitesses la justice le
système sanitaire
ils ce sont les pauvres qui sont
culpabilisés alors que les russes se
gavent
je n'ai rien personnellement contre les
personnes qui ont réussi leur vie
au contraire je m'en réjouis pour eux en
revanche nous pouvons pas laisser de
côté les personnes qui n'y arrivent pas
et malheureusement beaucoup de familles
sont dans le besoin
le 15 ils ne peuvent plus joindre les
deux bouts
et ce n'est pas logique à mon sens c'est
peut-être une opération de recasement
d'anciens ministres à des manuels macron
avec le dernier remaniement
certains ont quitté l'exécutif mais
n'ont pas pour autant tout perdu
beaucoup ont pu retrouver un poste
parfois grâce un sérieux coup de pouce
du président les précisant c'est avec
thomas bowness on aurait pu croire que
les ministres nous reconduit dans leurs
fonctions respectives avaient été
sanctionnés qui les avait été écarté car
pas forcément en adéquation avec la
politique souhaitée par le président et
sa nouvelle équipe gouvernementale
finalement parmi les personnalités qui
ont été remerciés au début du mois de
juillet beaucoup ont déjà rebondi
la dernière en date c'est muriel
pénicaud l'ancien ministre du travail a
été nommée ambassadrice de la france à
l' ocde
un poste qu'elle doit à une proposition
de jean yves le drian son ancien
collègue est toujours ministre des
affaires étrangères pas de retour dans
le privé donc pour l'ancien drh du
groupe danone qui a pu compter sur de
solides recommandations pour obtenir ce
nouvel emploi
idem en ce qui concerne agnès buzyn
après avoir quitté le gouvernement pour
remplacer au pied levé benjamin griveaux
dans la course à la mairie de paris
l'ancien ministre de la santé peut-elle
aussi compter sur le soutien de
l'exécutif et celui du président de la
république en particulier
selon le canard enchaîné emmanuel macron
envisagerait de nommer agnès buzyn
la tête d'universcience est un
établissement public qui regroupe le
palais de la découverte et la cité des
sciences et de l'industrie de paris
une belle opportunité pour celle qui a
connu un échec cuisant lors des
élections municipales de leur côté
christophe castaner et si bête ndiaye
ont pu rebondir en interne au sein de la
république en marche
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur vise la
présidence du groupe de la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée tandis que
l'ancien porte parole du gouvernement a
été choisie pour intégrer la commission
nationale des talents au sein du parti
on pourra également souligner le retour
aux affaires de françois bayroux
éphémère garde des sceaux en 2017
le président du modem va être nommé haut
commissaire au plan
un recyclage assumer notamment pour
permettre à emmanuel macron de conserver
certains soutiens dans son entourage
comme l'attestent ces verbatim publié
dans un article du parisien
un été pour rebondir au gré de
nomination là où le président a besoin
d'envoyer des signaux et d'avoir des
relais des antennes décrypte un proche
sont jean aussi au vaste mouvement dans
la préfectorale
un été pour trouver à se recaser même si
ce n'est pas très nouveau monde
cela a eu lieu de tout temps renvoie
d'ailleurs un marcheur c'est vrai que le
recyclage est une manoeuvre politique
ancienne mais compenser quelque peu
éculé le nouveau monde devait présenter
nouvelle manière de diriger de nouveau
visage aussi au final on constate que
certaines pratiques demeurent malgré les
critiques qu'elle suscite alors
opération d'euros casa ou pas écouter
l'analyse de benjamin morel docteur en
science politique et maître de
conférences à l'université paris ii vous
avez en effet d'anciens ministres
d'anciens secrétaires d'état on va
recasé à des postes diplomatiques
histoire d'avoir on va dire une
possibilité de rebond après une carrière
politique qui n'a pas été heureuse c'est
quelque chose qui se fait depuis très
très longtemps qui est profondément
problématique on peut en être d'accord
c'est pas nouveau ça montre que là
dessus et a pas vraiment de rupture dans
ce type de pratiques qui sera incarné
par emmanuel macron le deuxième cas
c'est celui de françois bayrou
là on est face à quelque chose de très
très différents en réalité il s'agit
aujourd'hui de reconsolider majorité qui
est profondément frais
gilles à l'assemblée nationale et qui
tient aujourd'hui en grande partie grâce
au modèle emmanuel macron a le luxe de
se fâcher avec françois bayrou parce que
sont françois bayrou il ne contrôle en
fait que l'assemblée nationale et donc
il ne contrôle plus la fin de son mandat
en biélorussie la contestation se
poursuit contre le président alexandre
loukachenko
cet après midi encore un amx et sur le
front diplomatique on le rappelle par et
bruxelles s'oppose à un éventuel soutien
sécuritaire rousse russes ont fait le
point avec emilie google le chef de la
diplomatie de l'union européenne a
profité de la réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères à berlin pour faire
passer un message à moscou lors de la
conférence de presse finale dans la
capitale allemande
josette borel a demandé au kremlin de ne
pas intervenir sur le territoire
biélorusse
j'ai souvent entendu de la part de la
russie le mantra selon lequel il s'agit
d'une affaire intérieure pour la
biélorussie et qu'elle ne veut pas
d'ingérence extérieure
je suppose que c'est également valable
pour les russes quelques heures plus
tard c'est au tour du président français
de donner son avis dans ce dossier pour
emmanuel macron une intervention russe
en biélorussie serait le pire qui puisse
arriver toute intervention extérieure en
biélorussie conduirait à
internationaliser cette question et le
pire et l'intervention russe
notre volonté d'engager la russie dans
un dialogue sur la biélorussie et de
nous aider à convaincre le président
lukashenko de la nécessité d'accepter
une médiation de l'eau a eu ce que le
président poutine a pu dire à la
chancelière merkel et à moi même c'est
que lui était favorable à une médiation
au sc eux mais pas le président
loukachenko
donc il a des efforts à faire pour nous
aider en ce sens
ce jeudi le président russe a appelé les
parties à un règlement de la crise
autour d'une table entre les anti et pro
nous cache un couple si la situation
devenait hors de contrôle vladimir
poutine s'est dit prête à déployer des
militaires chez le voisin biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko m'a demandé de
constituer une certaine réserve d'agents
des forces de l'ordre et je les fais
mais nous
avons également convenu que cette
réserve ne sera pas utilisée tant que la
situation ne sera pas devenu
incontrôlable
nous partons du principe que tous les
problèmes existant aujourd'hui en
biélorussie seront réglées par des
moyens pacifiques
le président biélorusse confronté depuis
trois semaines à une vague de
protestation semble vouloir trouver un
consensus
alexandre loukachenko s'est dit ce jeudi
prête à envisager une révision de la
constitution et d'en débattre avec une
frange de la population
je suis prêt à dialoguer avec la
communauté étudiante du pays
c'est la même chose pour les collectifs
de travailleurs je l' ai déjà dit
veuillez choisir vos représentants et
nous maintiendrons un dialogue tout le
monde veut un nouveau système politique
cela ne me dérange pas partons de la
constitution actuelle
faites vos propositions et nous
rédigerons une nouvelle constitution la
loi fondamentale de tout pays
tout doit être basée sur la constitution
c'est ma vision du dialogue et sur ceux
avec qui nous pouvons l'entretenir
si l'opposition à des gens sensés qui
voient leur pays libre et indépendant
alesi dites ce que vous pensez mais pas
dans la rue il n'y aura pas de dialogue
en biélorussie sous la pression de la
rue
pour l'instant aucune rencontre n'était
inscrite à l'agenda entre pouvoir et
opposition
en attendant les manifestations
continuent ce week end avec d'un côté
les anti loukachenko et de l'autre ses
soutiens jeudi la dmr poutine avait
commenté dans une interview la situation
en biélorussie où d'importantes
manifestations se succèdent depuis
l'annnonce on l'a dit la réélection
d'alexandre loukachenko il avait alors
appelé au dialogue tout en se disant
prêt à déployer des forces dans le pays
voisin c'est la situation venait à
dégénérer on va rejoindre à notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
fin
antoine la deuxième partie de
l'interview de vladimir poutine vient
d'être diffusée que faut-il en retenir
il a surtout été question dans cette
seconde partie du crédit à apporter aux
résultats de l'élection du 9 août tels
qu'ils ont été annoncés par les
autorités électorales biélorusse des
résultats contestés on l'a vu par de
nombreuses chancelleries occidentales
il ya cette question de la dir poutine a
tendance à remettre en question
l'opinion de ceux qui remettent en
question l'honnêteté des résultats à
écouter aubry si les autorités
biélorusses sont invités le bureau des
institutions démocratiques et des droits
de l'homme de l'osce cea participé à
l'observation des élections
pourquoi ne sont ils pas allés cela fait
tout de suite penser que leur position
sur les résultats de l'élection ont été
préparés d'avancé
quelqu'un peut donc remettre en question
les résultats mais moi j'ai toutes les
raisons de remettre en question
l'honnêteté absolue de ceux qui les
remettent en question
c'est pourquoi nous partons du principe
que les élections se sont bien tenues
nous avons reconnu leur légitimité
je les fais tout de suite dit il
comme vous le savez j'ai félicité
alexandre grigorievitch lukashenko pour
sa réélection c'est tout jeudi vladimir
poutine s'était dit prêt à faire
intervenir en biélorussie une force de
réserve si les événements venait à
dégénérer
une intervention russe en biélorussie
qui si elle devait avoir lieu ce serait
le pire qui puisse arriver à d'ailleurs
déclaré emmanuel macron bien l'entendre
cependant le président russe part du
principe que les problèmes actuels que
traverse la biélorussie vont se résoudre
de manière pacifique
un appel au dialogue qui a trouvé un
écho du côté d'alexandre loukachenko qui
s'est dit disposé à négocier avec la
société civile allant même jusqu'à
envisager une réforme constitutionnelle
et de nouvelles élections
est ce que ce sera néanmoins suffisant
pour apaiser la rue
réponse ces prochaines semaines merci à
vous on trinque l'hérault pour toutes
ces précisions en direct depuis moscou
font en libye maintenant le ministre de
l'intérieur fathi
baraka a suspendu provisoirement une
décision prise hier par fayez faraj a le
chef du gouvernement libyen d'union
nationale après que des hommes armés ont
tiré à balles réelles sur des
manifestants pacifiques est les faits
remontent à dimanche lundi et mercredi
dernier il a une plusieurs blessés elle
est ministre suspendu doit répondre à
une enquête administrative sur ces
propos tenus lors de ces événements l
ong amnesty international a évoque
l'enlèvement d'au moins 6 personnes à
tripoli par une milice sous l'autorité
du ministère de l'intérieur du
gouvernement d'accord national
excédées par des années de conflits
depuis la chute du guide libyen mouammar
kadhafi
la population descend dans la rue pour
exprimer son ras-le-bol face à la
corruption notamment le pays est divisé
entre deux pouvoirs on va en parler tout
de suite avec david rigoulet roze
spécialiste de la géopolitique du moyen
orient
[Applaudissements]
on saura vous merci à d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france la suspension du
ministre de l'intérieur est ce qu'elle
va à réussir à calmer la colère des
libyens le problème c'est que la
situation se dégrade rapidement
effectivement il ya eu une répression de
manifestations le week end dernier avec
plusieurs manifestations qui se
poursuivent par la suite et donc le chef
de l'exécutif du gouvernement d'entente
nationale sa rage a décidé de moments
tellement de suspendre effectivement le
ministre de l'intérieur fathi bachagha
et en os motif qu' il y avait
effectivement une grande confusion et
que et d'aucuns accuserait le ministre
de l'intérieur d'avoir éventuellement
encouragé les manifestations justement
manifestation qui stigmatise et la
corruption endémique et puis le la
dégradation des conditions de vie qui
sont qui sont patentes aujourd'hui à la
fois en termes d'accès à l'eau de
l'électricité etc et donc mais en
arrière-plan se joue aussi un duel
personnel parce que le ministre de
l'intérieur était un poids lourd du
gouvernement et il était de plus en plus
perçue par faïza chirac comme on va dire
comme un rival de plus en plus
encombrant et c'est le signe de tensions
non pas seulement entre l'ès de la vie
mais aussi au sein même du gouvernement
dit d'entente nationale
est ce que le gouvernement justement
d'entente nationale de fayez faraj est
fragilisé par ses manifestations
oui les fragiliser d'abord il est
fragile sur le fond puisque de toute
façon la sécurité de tripoli entre entre
guillemets est supposé être assuré par
une force de protection mais qui en fait
une re le groupe venant de
d'une myriade de 2010 est la question la
problématique milicienne justement était
est un enjeu considérable aujourd'hui
est d'ailleurs le miso intérieur a eu a
fait plusieurs déclarations en ce sens
où il s'agissait de justement de
soumettre les milices un ordre étatique
est donc là évidemment derrière ce
derrière le rideau se joue à la fois la
problématique clinicienne et les
allégeances de ces milices ou à
l'establishment politique et c'est à
dire la complexité de la situation
aujourd'hui à tripoli alors le contexte
aussi on le rappelle est un pays qui est
divisée il ya d'une part ce gouvernement
d'union nationale reconnue par la
communauté internationale de fayyad et
sarah jay puis il ya le camp du maréchal
haftar il ya eu il ya eu un accord pour
un cessez le feu qui reste fragile dans
ce contexte là que faut-il attendre
oui un cessez le feu qui a été annoncé
effectivement de part et d'autre
d'ailleurs le le chef d'exécutif fayyad
et sa rage a évoqué la perspective
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives à venir en mars prochain
avec toutes les incertitudes qui sont
sous-jacentes à ce type de déclarations
quand on voit la réalité de la situation
sur le terrain puisque très très souvent
la situation échappe
justement à ceux qui sont censés la
maîtrise est donc pour l'instant les
choses restent en l'état c'est à dire
qu'il ya un partage de fête en fête de
la libye entre l'est et l'ouest qui est
avec un affront qui gelé sur une ligne
entre syrte et une base militaire au sud
donc la question pour l'instant aux
militaires et potentiels probable
momentanément gelé mais il n'est pas dit
que la situation demeure celle là et et
les incertitudes qui déballent justement
à tripoli même langage rien bon et le
rôle de la communauté internationale
pour soutenir justement ces efforts de
paix
une lueur un espoir de paix dans pour la
libye oui la déclaration justement de
cessez-le-feu a été saluée évidemment
par l'onu et par toutes les parties
prenantes notamment européennes qui qui
considère que c'est une étape
indispensable justement pour faire
avancer le processus politique
mais ce processus politique est le
traître est largement tributaire des
justement de la complexité des acteurs
sur le terrain et de cette logique
milicienne que j'évoquais précédemment
qui d'une certaine manière vit sur le
dos de l'état et les intérêts de ces
différentes ministre qui ne sont pas
tous sur la même longueur d'onde
ailleurs rendre très très difficile
effectivement des choix politiques qui
qui permettrait de stabiliser la
situation
alors vous parlez du très rapidement du
rôle des milices et le rôle de l'état
islamique est présent également dans le
pays
oui alors il est de nouveau
effectivement le métal islamique a de
nouveau fait parler de lui notamment
dans une ville à sabratah rien mais il
avait été extrêmement réduit notamment
sous la pression militaire du maréchal
haftar à syrte et dans l'ouest dont il
ya une résurgence mais qui est cette
résurgence est aussi tardif et stations
de la déliquescence générale qui prévaut
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
effectivement on pouvoir suffisamment
établis pour faire régner un ordre sur
l'ensemble du pays voire sur tripoli est
et l'ouest garde donc ses cesmo reçu
effectivement de 2,7 de cette situation
qui est extrêmement fragmenté et
délétère ci avoue david hare il voulait
rose et ciani stade de la géopolitique
du moyen orient directeur de la revue
aurions stratégique chercheurs également
à l'iris
au mali maintenant la junte donne de
mauvais signe elle avait promis de
transférer le pouvoir aux civils mais
elle a reporté aujourd'hui une réunion
avec plusieurs organisations a par
ailleurs la communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest exige une
transition civile immédiate et des
élections d'ici 12 mois en échange d'une
levée des sanctions envoient tout cela
avec un élèment masculine près de dix
jours après le putsch qui a renversé le
président et breil boubacar kéita
les militaires refusent toujours de
regagner leurs casernes
le renversement du pouvoir par le groupe
d'officiers a mis fin au mouvement de
contestation qui agite est le pays
depuis les élections législatives
contestées de mars avril mai les
colonels désormais aux commandes sont
surveillés de près par les pays voisins
les dirigeants de la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest la cedeao qui soutenait le
président face à l'opposition ont imposé
des sanctions économiques au mali deux
jours seulement après le coup d'état
il demande aux militaires insurgés
d'engager une transition civile au plus
vite
demande aux responsables du cnsp
d'engager une transition civile
immédiatement en consultation avec la
conventionnelle les partis politiques
les organisations de la société civile
et tous les autres acteurs qui peuvent
contribuer à la mise en place de
solutions de sortie de crise aucune
structure militaire debré est au dessus
du président de la transition les
figures de la contestation dans le pays
qui ont rassemblé des milliers de
manifestants dans les rues se montrent
quant à eux prudents à l'égard des
militaires après s'être félicité de leur
initiative et demande à jouer un rôle
dans la transition politique et ville
je me dis que c'était le message clair
[Applaudissements]
que personne personne je dis bien
personne
[Musique]
les militaires ont promis de mettre en
place des élections dans un délai qu'il
promette raisonnable en attendant les
pays voisins disent officiellement
craindre que le vide institutionnel au
mali ne favorise les ambitions des
djihadistes dans la région mais certains
dont le pouvoir est contestée
redouterait également une contagion
révolutionnaire et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve en direct dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression l'étude démontre
la nocivité de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
au nom de la peur de la mort notre
ministre a interdit immédiatement son
utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise l'ouest font
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous sommes en compagnie
d'anne soupart écrivaine théo d'hygiène
bibliste catholique bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous en 2008 vous fondez le
comité de la jupe pour lutter contre la
discrimination des femmes dans l'église
après que le cardinal andré vingt-trois
interrogés sur leur rôle dans la
célébration des offices a déclaré le
plus difficile est d'avoir des femmes
formées le tout n'est pas d'avoir une
jupe mais quelque chose dans la tête 12
ans plus tard début 2000 20 vous postulé
à la succession du cardinal barbarin
comme archevêque de lyon une double
provocation parce que à la fois dans
l'église catholique on n'est pas
candidat à cette fonction c'est le pape
qui choisit ensuite parce que seul un
prêtre peut être évêque est donc un
homme votre candidature a très peu de
chances d'aboutir alors pour quelle
raison la proposer expliqué nous parce
qu'il ya un plafond de verre qui empêche
les femmes d'être pleinement reconnus
dans leur propre église
les femmes sont très actives dans
l'église catholique elle occupe quantité
de fonctions mais elles ne sont jamais
parfaitement responsable il y a toujours
un prêtre qui les supervise et elles ne
sont jamais autonomes dans leur dans
leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière dans leur
propre église
donc il est temps il est temps de dire
que l'église ne peut pas fonctionner sur
un seul de ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une seule
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change et
c'est pour cela que ma candidature
intervient alors vous n'êtes pas la
seule puisque un nouveau vent féministe
semble souffler sur l'église catholique
puisque dans votre sillon sept autres
femmes viennent tout juste de proposer
leur candidature à des postes réservés
aux hommes y diacre prêtre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut être catholique
et féministe facilement